yo what is up guys my name is prestige
hello all of you people and this is my
fifth episode of my divine survival
series or something of the sort and this
is for all of you knew this is where i
go through minecraft and i play with the
divine RPG mod you can see with my
swords my tools and armor and it's not
like complete survive like I don't show
everything but I kind of just show big
events in it but yeah so recently I went
to the nether got some another stuff got
some really my god I killed a ton of
ancient entities to get the enough
divine shards to make for divine stones
and 33 extra divine shards plus some
others that I've already placed but you
see because you mix the divine shards
with the UH with stone and get divine
rock I thought you had to build a like
yeah it wasn't what I thought before
blow it up well we are going to finish
the clock finish the clock no finish the
portal I've only thing I only needed to
I want the heck and even go through it
fail I really needed Dean otherwise this
yeah so 12 and let's go check to see if
I can put this back out so I'm going to
make the divine sword since the divine
sword is infinite and I think it does
more damage than the aquat on which ours
ball in just say so we can throw the
Devon rock backs and I don't think I
need to use it for anything else again
just let me sit the divine shard but
whatever so throw you three right there
switch that all right now we have a
stick now the divine sword is made not
like it a normal sword divine swears 29
melee damage it's insane this one does a
18 so this guy's boss any infinite of
it's gonna be so good can be so good
took so long and I'll also i enchanted
some books so i got a charm is one is
better than nothing so until i get
something better i'm going to do that up
there goes my hand rail let's make
ourselves a new anvil nope you
starting on iron I think 30 yeah 30
mention i should be enough with your
three one two three one two three one
two three okay not that ok I was that I
did that wrong ok and boom boom boom
boom and boom boom boom ok so you're
like when i get more better sharpness i
can just put it on the sword so that's
why i did that and yeah i made a new
thing for books yeah so let's throw the
iron back in there still another bike oh
I went to the i said i went to another
get some more ores I got one another
brac because this thing is pick destroys
okay actually I'm going to get you in
there so we got good backup sword that's
my backup just all right where we need
to see if of e I'll uh put it mysterious
clock was it serious clock tashu tell i
think i put in here yeah white wine
o'clock Mr Clarke Swansea ancient empty
okay that cows escaped time to kill them
with the divine sword actually no but
this since that cooks the me and gives
me extra stuff with lutein so yeah
that's better it's better till I get
lutein I won't be able I won't use this
guy for like killing shots but I use
them for the other stuff come on work
yeah all the looks of sexy look so sexy
bro I'm thinking of making out which one
all to an all or whatever we'll make it
work somehow but i'm thinking of it i'm
wishing i want to change it now i'm
gonna change now
however then mr. Skeletor I'm just going
to block your face in black now put air
up there and I already hate to do it
here is where I want it if you get you
yeah yeah yeah and I'm going to break
you break you and place place place and
which I'll probably tastes like that
just get rid of it get rid of it okay so
um should we just venture in oh no let's
not lose all of our stuff let's throw
some stuff back there like a Twilight
clock the same the same / does do more
damage checking even the divine sword
want to name the device or something now
we're going to be using the divine
swords that we get a better one which
can be pretty hard to beat the 19 mainly
damage plus infinity and we're going to
put throw the Twilight clock in there
going to throw the leather and they're
just other stuff that I don't like need
to take with it I could use I'm going to
take that I want to take that out take
my bow torches I've ever done and can i
can afford these everything Oh mr.
Cyclops I was about to call him an ogre
I always called them overs and to drive
right let's go bowling alright alright
first like real actual dimensions as the
snow dimension doesn't count because
it's kind of like a side to mention that
was easy to get to annoying yeah I don't
like it I don't like it at all oh dang
okay so we're going to have to we're
gonna have to find out who is hostile I
think those things fun they're hostile
oh my gosh it's that is in a known i
know oh my gosh that's going to be
someone this looks so much like dry rock
so what is this Twilight stone
okay let's cook some stuff since this
thing breaks everything and it breaks
everything really fast that is annoying
as I just know that what it would take
back what's that bad as this can harm me
kind of jungle baskin army so wanna hear
i get is bad you can't do crap oh there
was something and there's that thing and
that looks like multicolored or I'm
gonna get that light this up let's try
to not get that guy oh that guy's pissed
off a medieval um you are creepy yes oh
my divine sword is even more names I
think those things that are flying or
really powerful so I'm gonna want to
avoid oh god you shooting me I don't
know oh how do I am ok ok ok I'll
bunnies there are bunnies my phone is
blowing up stop texting me when I'm
building video people's azu dirt if
someone doesn't attack me I'm doing this
ok so it takes moderate to break as
compared to everything else and like the
other in over world that breaks in two
seconds so that is called Dravet
fragments so thank you drew I need
traffic fragments to get to the next
world is the next world drive it I'm
going to assume so drive aight know this
world is dr I what the heck i really
wish i had that armors let me fly I
gotta park with this then I was sick um
I think this guy can only hit me so if I
hit him like he does have a range attack
so let's finish him off with this
eyeliner cooks to me he gives me oh gosh
oh we got asked out some things that
respond 800 health 300 health um
we're not going to fight those things
they have 300 health yeah up not its
rich rod doesn't cook it even raw
replenishes 5 hunger that's the jits on
the Gipe a lot of world errors not
errors just spawning also I can't like
epic break through dirt that makes me
sad this breaks things like this fast is
like a normal pic what the heck bro is
my roof ishik acts not working i don't
know i mean i think i need to find its
kind of bunny give me anything I test it
out yeah oh gosh oh gosh oh my gosh that
freaked me out oh gosh oh my gosh okay I
think I need these things drive eight
souls I don't know how to kind of crap
oh wait Trevor fragments so I think say
i do that i crashed them okay i cain't
can't grab them that that is dry by does
that's used like his ammo okay I just
want to check something so I'm gonna
spare this wood benchmarking yet I you
did what I don't get white Sun saving my
achievements we're going to keep you
here so how do this unless I can work
stop it drive like block so that's one
block and to get to the new dimension so
killing people so killing bunnies oh my
gosh the thing freaked me out it's angry
bunny you can see I don't know that much
about this it's a cotillion yeah 15
arrows and ranged attack powers
okay i'm going to try killing the
cotillion um he's not a growing on me
long Tigers and I don't wanna go over
say hi to that guy since I can kill like
I but ok this guy moves fast but we can
we're supposed to be able to keep him at
bay just sometimes the hitboxes on this
game are really weird ok he can give me
anything I won't like this up something
so swollen okay this guy's gonna pissed
off of me and yeah this he's all this
guy's really slow yes is the perfect
item ok now we're going to change to the
blood gem and thank you for your good
skit sir so one soul equals one fragment
ok it's easy enough easy enough this is
really dark
wow that is loud oh why I fell spawn
behind me I don't like it when this one
behind me okay i don't want i want to
attract these guys it looks like this
shooting Cory's they have like no health
Oh almost got that guy what things that
noise ok let's try not a green him so i
thought i saw another one ok we have
those things probably gonna have to
learn how to fight those things so you I
still haven't experienced his hitting
power so how about how do we don't
experience that and you Wow ok so I just
want to check something Oh Pooh ok we
still get a little more time if you're
doing my videos I do that a lot so get
used to it since that's that's how we're
checking how long I've been recording I
don't think it's I always forgot to
tricking you clock oh I should have
bought my other gear and I'm going to
get this gear because I back up gear is
ok um you get pissed off at me so um can
I go around since yeah okay there's the
freaking Cory thing ok screw you bro I
don't have any arrows ok let's just
dodge dodge dodge dodge dodge ok one hit
okk arrows arrows arrows one hit of em
all really aight i get a hit and it does
eight damage
okay the [ __ ] at me screw you guys
teaming up it's unfair like Adele ian
has kabillion crap screw you cotillion
not it this is really freaking like
beautiful okay I don't think in chase oh
ho ho ho got all my armor on get my
sword out okay imma kill honey okay okay
dead now okay then um an s ro Oh brick
oh frick frick frick no go away No Oh
auntie his armor that's great oh that is
I hate that noise I hate that noise so
much I hate your noise go away die ah I
hate it took hate the Endermen noises oh
gosh okay i can prob I the cotillion I
don't want to fight the tomo so it looks
like he doesn't get pissed off unless he
like two inches from him come on I've no
more arrows come on bro it's fight you
still are you pissed at me nope nope we
still freaking not pissed at me what the
heck yeah I don't even want to try if
anyone listen with 800 health hey could
alien over here you guys don't get a
great at all I just have to hit them
from get a grip or I have a lot of
flying things don't like those okay you
drop nothing thank you Wow dang it every
time they have 10 health and yet they do
I guess so I'm there's also this mod
that uh keeps all my items in my
inventory on me when I die I'm gonna get
that just because it just uh that's a
nice noise when I spawn oh you I'm gonna
get that mod because i am annoyed but
tyne and having to get my stuff in this
dimension it's been fairly easy to
retrieve my stuff but other ones not so
much
Cory's too lame to me screw you Korra
scree upper okay that is annoying noise
oh my i think that the quarries that's
that is also i want flying I want flying
freakin armor so I can kill those things
we're going back let's go come on come
up let's go there we go ow thank you
tell people I'm going to definitely have
to redo this oh we have one drive aight
block and that this should be used in
the creation of the heat next place so
this this divine sword should rectal
okay we have five driver like fragments
so that's good on a way to build in our
second block so let's put rabbit stuffed
rabbit out and whatever it doesn't
matter okay let's let's cook up some of
these dis here meats and there's
anything okay we can put our blocks
drive either and why so I think twilight
zone isn't allowed yellow logs oh that's
nice yellow nice what's up that one
cooked empower me nice I think we can
end the video there guys we explore
drive it that was cool and we know that
I want okay so also i was talking about
this is armor can sparkle has a reason
to know about it it's made with ice
stones and blue fire stones and it is a
called divine armor and it lets you fly
and i want i want to have the ability to
fly so we can get that so yeah alright
guys I hope you i'm going to end up
outside hope you look it's like all
perfectly goes together hope you enjoyed
this video my name is prestige if you
did leave a like comment rate subscribe
and see you later